baby Bradley initiate dolphins it takes
them out of what they're trying to do
[Applause]
see he's thinking so they see plenty of
that this sequence thing about you
talking what they love to do is drive
the scenes whether it be awful
pick-and-roll action or just driving
kick action they accept land getting
each other involved
it's changed the game out sighs the end
yet so you're going by the playground
and engineering people say no no that
was the second step after the gap
absolutely love specifics on what they
can and can't challenge throughout the
game when it inevitably comes up as free
here is Bradley Roby James behind the
back
Bradley sets himself up for to this good
offense good pass by LeBron patience by
Avery Bradley getting Mike Tompa makes
on misses they got to push the basket
get a chance here
[Applause]
no good for Davis green the offensive
board that's an easier for Anthony Davis
little two-man game Breen and Davis
Davis that shake
caldwell-pope gets his hands on that
pass Davis lobs it up fringes foot man
he was going to the past
but instead it's gonna be a jumper for
Anthony Davis throw the LOB passive
Dwight Howard and oops look what I found
that's when you know things are going
well for me they gave up 40 points in
the second quarter Tuesday night against
the Clippers James we poor help
initially direct blind driving these two
guys through the grip of Bradley another
chance to the cast breathe fight the
scene fun finish we played great defense
the Javan struggled head of the
six-point ball game and they're
presented multiple effort stop the ball
get back into the pitches block the dump
way up attempt by Davis and any Flags it
did
13th turnover from the Jazz in this
first half he is staying in the game
despite that it was attended to during
the timeout change shovels Davis
finishes get Quinn cook on Donovan
Mitchell much better than the aggressive
then Avery Bradley defending look good
job beautiful
[Applause]
that's just getting it done get him to
basketball
[Applause]
what about effortless precision and then
the big fella the agility the Euro step
avoiding the contact with the finish
doesn't get that to drop either he's
vote for five in this verse - James
storming down the floor this
James methodically massaging his
[Applause]
Michell water no latina then go there
he's stoned as the Rimbaud David Onley
peddled his way into bodies and turns it
over
three on two three
those two guys - played very well for
the first two games - maverick says
people who wins James that Davis Crump
sit down
this is a well-designed play out of the
timeout little pick-and-roll action with
Davis at the five dive into the cup on
point lob pass from LeBron James and
Anthony Davis does the rest
that's beautiful camerawork right there
sometimes it's got to be yourself
there's nothing wrong with typing
yourself up until you get this finally
over six from the floor tonight
[Applause]
eight points for Gobert seven rebounds
James Wade will the bronze sees bodies
he turns the corner and sees nothing but
a purple seeker looking to cheat his way
to some space turned it over here comes
James to cook none James on the
offensive glass foot today he misses the
second follows it up still time to
operate for LA Daniel's pitch rhythm
dribble you got
20 is also the amount of fuel goals Utah
has this evening James fading away oh
yeah she was at the Brooklyn Knicks game
tonight I know he's very thrilled with
what she's doing right now
appreciate service
[Applause]
for the fam LeBron making an
announcement tonight the party's not
over
you lyin BAM I sure the Davis the
deflection Caldwell hostess steel
turnover number 21 for Utah 14 points
off the bench for Daniel Mitchell that I
by Davis his fifth rejection of the
night James Davis working a little
two-man game ten assists seven rebounds
for LeBron James the season where LeBron
is gonna say get me the basketball get
out of my way and not settle for a
contestant 3-pointer get to yo spot
that's a hot mark would you just looked
at their roster I mean how did you
project their deep end
here is James funny house what's up you
guys this Taylor Brooks with bleacher
report make sure that you subscribe for
some more video content